SUMIT CHANDEL: Hi , guys.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Sumit Chandel,
Developer Advocate on the
AdWord API.
What I'll be talking about
today is mobile best
practices, catching up
with a moving target.
So this is the agenda.
The first item is just how
important is mobile?
So we'll look at that and
look at some trends.
After covering how important it
is, then we'll look at how
to set them up using the API.
We'll look at targeting
campaigns, so how to target
mobile campaigns, setting up
mobile extensions, using call
metrics, which is a new feature
introduced in the
AdWords front end and is
available to some degree
through the API as well.
And then finally, mobile
campaign performance
reporting, and we'll look at
how to track performance of
these campaigns using the
new reports for this.
OK, so just how important
is mobile?
The answer is really
important.
In fact, there's a whole mobile
movement going on.
Now I'll apologize because I'm
about to show you guys a
YouTube video, which is loaded
with marketing terms, and I
know that we are mostly
engineers here.
But there are some really
interesting numbers that are
presented in that video, so
it's somewhat appealing.
At least it was to me
when I first saw it.
So hopefully, it's appealing
to you guys as well.
Getting back to my slightly less
interesting slides, this
is a quote from Mary Meeker.
Some of you guys might
recognize her.
She actually wrote "The Internet
Report" back in 1995
and talked about the internet
movement and how important
e-commerce was going to be and
how important it was to get an
online presence.
She also recently was quoted
saying mobile is ramping
faster than any other
technology
we've seen in the past.
So that's a pretty strong
statement considering that she
wrote "The Internet
Report," which
itself was a huge movement.
So the move to mobile
is happening
even faster than that.
Some more interesting stats
to share with you guys.
So the mobile web
is exploding.
The graph here shows US mobile
queries and the growth that
we've seen over the last year.
As you can see, the y-axis is
in net so we don't actually
show the exact numbers.
But it's just to give an idea
what the trend looks like and
that in the last year we've
seen a 4x growth in mobile
search queries in the US.
Another trend we've seen is that
mobile internet usage is
soon going to surpass desktop
internet usage.
So it hasn't happened yet.
But if current trends continue,
we do see that
happening in mid-2013.
Another interesting data point
is mobile allows for constant
connectivity.
For an average user, on an
average day, the usage of
internet through a PC or through
a mobile device-- so
you can see around lunchtime
when people leave the office,
it dips for desktop usage.
That's when mobile actually
picks up.
Later on in the evening around
6:00 PM, desktop
usage again drops off.
And you see mobile is actually
rising and actually surpasses
desktop usage near the late
hours of the night.
Mobile usage also complements
desktops.
So you can see, throughout
the week there
are dips on the weekend.
You can see throughout that,
there's still high or constant
mobile usage.
It spikes where desktop drops.
Some more interesting data,
actually this is a really
great website,
ourmobileplanet.com.
We, Google, are a partner with
that, and there's other
companies as well who apply
their data there.
This is a graph that
I generated from
that website, actually.
It's just tracking different
actions that users take after
performing a local
search and which
percentages take what actions.
So, as you can see, for example,
in the US, about 51%
of users who perform a local
search will end up calling the
business afterwards.
That speaks both to location
extensions for the local
search and mobile extensions
for the click-to-call, the
call to the business
afterwards.
So having seen just how
important mobile is, now let's
talk about how do we
set them up, so
getting to our main objective.
So the first step is targeting
campaigns.
We actually have criteria now
for all the different campaign
targets we might want to set.
So that's what we are
going to do here.
So we have a campaign let's
say we just created.
And now we want to set up the
targeting for this campaign.
We're going to look at the
different targets or criteria
objects that we'd want to set on
it to properly target this
new campaign, the first of which
will be the platform.
The different platforms
are desktop,
high-end mobile, and tablet.
These now correspond to these
criteria, these on the
right-hand side in
that table there.
This is an excerpt
from the SOAP that
you'd send in and request.
So you'd set a criteria on the
type of platform and set the
ID to 30001.
That corresponds to the
high-end mobile in the
previous slide we just saw.
The stuff in the grayed out
text, that's optional on
input, which you'll get
back in response.
What else might we
want to set?
The carrier.
That's another important target,
something that's
existed in previous versions
and something
that has changed now.
This is how you'd set it
in the new service.
So we have a different carrier
name and country code
combinations.
This is just a list
of some of them.
So let's say if we were to
target NTT DoCoMo in Japan.
The criteria ID there
is 70000.
And so similar to our previous
criteria type that we set, we
have another one that we set.
That's type carrier.
This time the ID is 70000.
And again, the grayed out text
is just to show that that's
optional on input that, which
you get back in response.
OK, so we've set the carrier.
We've set the platform.
What else might we set?
Operating system version.
So this is currently how we're
exposing the different mobile
OSes that we can target.
This might actually expand to
desktops as well and different
operating systems you
can target there.
For the time being,
this is the only
platform you have there--
Android, iOS and Palm.
Let's say we're going
to target Android.
So in this case, we also have
the criteria type that we're
going to set.
This time the type is
OPERATING_SYSTEM_VERSION.
And the ID we pass in
there is 630159.
That corresponds to Android.
Next, let's set up mobile
extensions.
So a mobile extension, like a
location extension, which I
also strongly recommend to use,
allows you to apply a
fifth line of text to the text
ads that you serve and
provides that extra line there
that you see at the bottom
with a phone number to call.
So you can set the mobile
attention of the campaign
level and any ads that are
living under that will show up
with that fifth line if they're
served on a mobile device.
So let's look at
how to do that.
This sample is actually
using v201101 Java
Client library code.
It's going to look
exactly the--
I think almost exactly the same
in the new version, so
the example is still
useful here.
So we create the mobile
extension.
We set the phone number--
it's a 514 number--
country code, and finally a
Boolean to set as call only.
It controls whether or not you
want the text to show up with
it with the ability to click
through to your web page or
only click-to-call.
So in that case, if it's set,
it's calling the false.
It's means that the user
has both options.
They can see the ad and click
through to your website, or
they can actually
click and call.
If that was set to true,
they could only call.
Next, we create the generic
campaign ad extension, and we
set the campaign ad extension to
the mobile extension, which
we just created.
And then finally, we create
our operation.
We set the operand, the
operator, and then we can
mutate call at the bottom
and get our result back.
OK, so using call metrics.
It's a number that we actually
generate on our side and that
we can put in as a click-to-call
number for your
ads, so we can basically
generate call metrics for you.
We can know how many users have
called, how long have the
calls lasted, how many missed
calls do you have, all that
kind of information.
So currently, call metrics can
only be set through the UI,
and it only targets the US and
Canada for the time being.
There are plans eventually to
expose it through the API and
that will be through the mobile
extension, through a
flag that you can set there.
To specify whether or not you
want to use your own number
and in cases where you're using
your own call tracking,
you might want to do that, or
if you'd like to use call
metrics and have us
auto-generate the number and
place it into your
mobile extension.
So this is just a screenshot of
what it looks like if you
want to set this in the UI.
A bit more info about call
metrics is the pricing.
So the way it works, if a user
does clicks and calls, it will
basically get charged the
same CBC that you bid.
The only time that's not the
case is if the user calls the
number directly without
clicking.
They just see the number and
pick up their landline phone
and then dial the number.
That's going to be a $1.00--
a one US-dollar charge.
Now, how do we track the
performance of these campaigns
that we're running?
We do that in the same way that
we do for all reporting.
We set up a report definition
that we'll pass in the request
payload where we're basically
selecting a bunch
of different fields.
So we're selecting date,
campaign ID, ad ID, and so
forth, clicks, click type--
that's an important one--
and device as well as one of
the additional fields.
Then we add predicates to the
filter on the fields that
we've selected.
Those predicates will
be on click type.
So this will help us isolate
calls, basically, click to
calls to isolate our mobile
campaigns, and then an extra
predicate there, which isn't
completely necessary.
I think if you filter on click
type already, you've basically
isolated it.
But you can also just
filter on device for
high-end mobile only.
That way, the reports you get
back are strictly for your
mobile campaigns.
All right, next is reporting
on call metrics.
For that, we've actually--
with the v201109 release,
we've included some new
columns in the report service
specifically for call metrics.
That's the ones that you see
here, so call duration
seconds, average call duration
seconds, number of calls,
number of missed calls, number
of received calls.
You can imagine that as this
call metrics feature matures,
there will be other fields here
as well, which you might
be able to get out.
For the moment, this is
what's available.
So this is what you can
include in your report
definitions as selectable
fields to report
on your call metrics.
And an important note about
this is that call metrics
reporting is only available
at the campaign level.
So there's a very good reason
why it isn't set up that way.
And you can only do it with
campaigns because we don't
have enough numbers to represent
the number of ads
that we're showing.
OK, any other questions?
All right, cool.